come here
i would never say this to her face but
she is a wonderful person and a gifted
artist why why wouldn't you say that to
her face so
hey hey
pam
pam
hey
what happened i wrote you a goodbye poem
it's really long i left it
up in my office could you just please
wait till i go get it i should really
get going no
okay okay
um
the last word is seagulls
i'm sure it was really lovely i took a
lot from other poems
call me when you get in okay
bye all right call
no michael
okay michael you know what i might have
someone for you
oh really what's her name burger king no
i mean it
she's really nice and sweet and
you guys might actually get along
don't i don't think i'm ready is she hot
i'm setting michael up with my landlady
she's really sweet
and
whatever i just can't take michael like
this
oh no what
i'm going with him
what
pam i'm going
pam
you can't be serious
michael wait
i'm coming with you
you are
yeah
okay it's gonna be great
great uh except i i don't wanna be a
receptionist anymore
right
executive assistant salesman
all right
okay
deal deal
okay well jim still know okay yeah
well let's go
oh all my stuff is still upstairs
are people watching
probably
michael that's not how you leave an
office yeah jam jim
we're having a company meeting here
i will bring all your stuff home okay
all right i'll see you later later
pam
you come in here please
have a seat
well there's no easy way of saying this
so i think i will just
drag it out
since the dawn of time just tell me
i gave ryan the sales job
there just weren't enough clients for
the two of you so i had to
oh sorry i'm sorry i get it
why are you giggling
is this a
joke michael is this
did i get the job
yes i did yeah for real you're not
kidding
me i didn't you're the best person for
the job you're gonna be great
okay thank you
thank you oh thank you oh you will not
be sorry
oh man
oh that was classic
i really thought i didn't get it oh
really
yeah
because you said i did good that was
really good what about ryan
i don't know i offered him his temp job
back we'll see
he was not happy at all when i offered
him this job and then i told him that he
didn't get the job though yeah maybe you
shouldn't fake fire people anymore i
don't appreciate you telling me what to
do so clean out your desk you are
through here
thanks michael oh
what's our receptionist name erin could
you send her in
you're the one who said we needed more
culture this is culture to you it's her
first try
yeah on van gogh's first try he drew the
hands of the peasants meaning what
meaning real art takes
courage okay and
honesty well those aren't pam strong
points yeah exactly that's why this is
motel art
thanks for coming
pam casso
sorry i'm late i had to race across town
oh michael
wow
you did these free hand
yep oh my god these could be tracings
oh
look at this one
wow
you nailed it
how much
what do you mean
i don't see uh price
um
you want to buy it
well yeah
yeah we have to have it for the office
there's my
window and there's my car
is that your car
uh-huh that is our building
and we sell paper
i am really proud of you
thank you what
do you have something in your pocket
chunky
no thank you
it is a message
it is an inspiration it is
a source of beauty
and without paper
it could not have happened
unless you had a camera
they say on your deathbed you never wish
you spent more time at the office
but i will
got to be a lot better than a deathbed
i actually don't understand deathbeds
i mean who would buy that
well
i guess this is it
hey will you guys let me know if this
ever airs
thank you
all right oh
this
is gonna feel so good getting this thing
off my chest
so
no he wasn't sad
he was full of hope
about colorado
and he was hoping to get an upgrade as
an awards member
and he said he was just really excited
to get home and see holly
[Music]
you